all right
125th Street
unscheduled services
[Music]
oh
[Music]
are you registered to vote
[Music]
all right
[Music]
that is so cool
I got you
hey thanks no problem
hey uh you think you're gonna add that
new Spider-Man too
the kid yeah maybe Original's just my
guy you know
yeah I know
hey is Tails Bodega around here yeah
bright yellow sign down the block can't
miss it
thanks
beautiful work by the way
maybe leave a little room for the new
guy just in case
the Convoy
foreign
[Music]
not yet we're still securing a couple
inmates but it feels good seeing the
guys who escaped last year going back to
the raft real good the ref's an eyesore
but it's secure as long as the octopus
related flaws have been fixed let's hope
okay closing in on you be there soon
[Music]
did you get the shopping list hey Mom
yeah but uh the bodega was out of
coconut milk I'm gonna check a store
downtown oh thank you but avoid Midtown
that prison Convoy is making traffic
oh yeah good call see you at dinner mom
man how does Pete do this secret
identity thing completely stresses me
out
foreign
okay be cool be cool helping Spider-Man
protect your giant prison Convoy you can
handle this Breathe In Breathe Out be
cool
Pete
you here just down in some rocket fuel
how are you
drinking very very carefully
okay go time
heavy payload copy Helix 2 we've got you
all scoped this is a big operation It's
gotta be hundreds of felons escaped from
the rap last year now it's time to move
them back in police aren't taking any
chances especially not with our guest of
honor
getting a lot of interference here one
of those guys who helped dot doctors in
there think so it could be vulture
scorpion could be someone bigger okay we
got a problem
don't worry
it's secure
we have a weighted balance
of responses for impact
going down
all right
Helix 2 is down no casualties payload
compromised Response Team dispatched sit
tight Helix too I'm sorry man I didn't
mean to it's okay we got this
just need to contain it before
that happened
Hello type spiders
foreign
no no all right then
nearly almost in pain
you can't live Pete down I need to get
this under control
[Music]
straight arms
seriously your AAA easy your whole new
career just playing historian
straight Spiderman honestly kind of
terrifying
Christmas in New York
guys
out wow
I got the keys
gotta get out of here
you're free
your holiday spirit's a little
overzealous this year Lexi
[Applause]
I'm coming
holy crap that's not good
oh hey sorry
[Applause]
how are we doing 10 for generating
pressure goes one for minimizing
destruction
worst thing out of this is a bad
headline I'm a countless lucky
don't think like that we're going to
stop him as long as we work together
I'm giving me a hand up here yeah get
out I got you
okay big [ __ ] I got this
hang on tight tiny spiders
and you're safe you too
wow do you have any non-destructive
quality fly fishing
that sounds nice
you know you're ruining Christmas right
the last six Christmases I was locked
behind 30 feet of field I intend to
enjoy this one
he's a menace yeah too soft he's a low
energy Menace too easy maybe he's a
weak-minded
very fast tell us a feckless treacherous
coconut milk still trying to find it
it's been kind of uh an adventure are
you running yeah uh sorry I'm trying to
catch a train
now we're never miles you've got to stop
him on our way
foreign
[Applause]
Pete are you okay
no
no no no okay I've got him headed your
way be ready okay
yeah
fighter I need a minute
[Music]
for the police maybe go bring RPG to the
prison Convoy next time maybe don't ring
RPGs anywhere
got a Lexi
man I'm trying to help you
hey it's getting hairy out here police
and escapees are shooting it out back up
the police
a little longer he's counting on me I've
gotta stop these guys
yeah they're all over that bridge
hang on man hang on
okay
Spider-Man you good
Pete Pete
wake up wake up wake up man
wake up man
Spiderman is broken I would like to
exchange for new one
this one will
last get out of here
[Music]
bro come back the hell
around me
tomorrow
I'm almost there
how am I even doing this electric sites
some kind of dude induction
well you're mentorships I won't expect
and you're using words longer than crush
and smash
you're not gonna keep pushing people
around Lexi
I'm not gonna let you hurt anyone else I
am excited to see you tonight
or I will come after you
all right
come on
CE yes
destroyed at the city don't you care
did he kind of feel like a Wilder what's
the word wow
I hate Jason dude
[Music]
man no more breakouts please
you alive calendar
guys
wow just wow
Simon Krieger head of r d at roxon
energy pleasure to meet you you too uh
sorry I think our ball landed in your
yard no it actually did us a favor we uh
just bought the place uh we're planning
to tear it down for a build
but uh looks like you beat us to it
I wanted to thank you
both of you
taken down rhino
solo
you are going places bud
thanks but he's still dangerous I will
hold him for the police you know I
always think these Super Troopers are
Overkill until
something like this happens oh Judy
calls hey uh really great to meet you
both
teachers looking bright
he's right yeah let's clear out
the police do their job
yeah yeah okay
I have electricity wow gotta be honest a
little jealous hey look I got nothing on
the OG I think we should run tests
tomorrow
a little voltage analysis oh man yeah
sorry I've been meaning to tell you I'm
not gonna be around for the next few
weeks
this is some kind of B joke I don't get
no uh MJ's headed overseas for the bugle
and requested me as her photographer
kind of a working vacation for us oh man
look I don't know if I'm ready to fly
solo I screwed up today big time with
the helicopter but then you delivered
big time you saved my bacon miles
I got lucky
hey I did this gig for eight years
without backup and you better believe I
screwed up lots of times but that is how
you learn
what's this Christmas present But first
you gotta take the oath oh
um okay
I promise to do everything in my power
to protect this city
I promise
that's it
that oh the real thing
totally definitely didn't just make it
up
see you in a few weeks Spiderman
New York's only Spider-Man
I'm New York's only